hey
a Florida woman is taken into custody
after attempting to stab a sheriff's
deputy with a tool used to fix flat
tires
stop I'm gonna you're gonna come through
now I'm not playing these which means
while you're back doing now
put your hands behind your back now
you're gonna get tased if you don't put
your hands by your back you know that
right on May 11th officials in Flagler
County Florida got an emergency call
about a woman riding her bike against
traffic almost causing multiple crashes
investigators say the woman 41 year old
Bree Anne Gallery was also keying
Vehicles as she rode past on her bike
come here now
body camera video shows a Flagler County
Sheriff's deputy respond to the scene
chasing after Gallery as he tries to
take her into custody she begins
shouting about TV producers
right now
all your fucking TVs you're gonna figure
it out now bring them out now Gallery
continues to reference being recorded on
video
we're trying to get her security system
you gotta bring them out
bring them out
yep put your hands on your back doing
that no
what are you doing this for because
y'all are fucking videoing me you know
you are I've told you to stop for years
you know stop at one point gathery
attempts to stab the sheriff's deputy
with what officials call a sharp fix a
flat tool
stop I'm gonna you're gonna come through
now I'm not playing with you which means
money back now
you're gonna get tased if you don't put
your hands by your back you know that
right during this time Gallery again
references a TV show and being recorded
more free TV yeah you think so more for
TV
move the TV right
is that what it is
right
that's what it is more for TV huh that's
what it is don't move I'm telling you
nice if you don't stop is that what it
is
more for TV right
yep
I'll be a TV show
TV show huh
I'm not the one
officials with the Flagler County
Sheriff's Office say Gallery continued
to resist arrest during the altercation
sheriff's deputies then used a taser to
get her under control
where'd you pick that up from
you see it no that though you've seen
that right there right oh yes that's
when she was having a garden okay even
after she was cuffed gatteri continued
to put up a fight with First Responders
[Applause]
yo where's all the cameras bring them
out
Gathering now faces multiple charges
including aggravated battery and
resisting an officer with violence she
also has an arrest history including
domestic violence and disorderly
intoxication reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie